[Musique]
moi
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent vous n
en soit vient de clignancourt
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
du musée la donation
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
il prône la désescalade sur le dossier
ukrainien vladimir poutine emmanuel
macron se sont entretenus par téléphone
à la mi journée les deux dirigeants ont
souligné l'importance des accords 2000
ce qu'est la poursuite des discussions
via le format normandie abandon la
question plus large de la sécurité en
europe le président russe a déploré que
l'occident ne tiennent pas compte des
préoccupations de la russie
[Musique]
le burkina suspendu de la communauté des
états d'afrique de l'ouest quatre jours
après le coup d'état militaire la cedeao
s'est réunis lors d'un sommet virtuel
elle exige la libération du président
renversé le nouvel enfant du burkina
assure que le pays continuera à
respecter ses engagements internationaux
il s'est également engagé au retour à
une vie constitutionnelle normale
lorsque les conditions seront réunies
[Musique]
l'argentine annonce à un accord avec le
fmi sur sa dette le pays faisait face à
de lourdes échéances de remboursement
sur trois ans l'accord prévoit le
maintien de la reprise économique déjà
entamée après trois ans de récession la
croissance dans le pays a atteint plus
de 11% pour les 11 premiers mois de 2000
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus si
vous n'êtes jamais sûr rt france
le ballet diplomatique non en finit pas
pour tenter de trouver une issue à la
crise du crédit yens 2 jours après la
réunion à paris au format normandie des
représentants russes ukrainiens allemand
et français la dîmière poutine emmanuel
macron se sont donc encore entretenu ce
vendredi en échange téléphonique au
cours duquel les deux dirigeants ont
convenu de poursuivre ses discussions à
quatre parties soulignant au passage
l'importance du respect des accords de
minsk a les détails de cette
conversation depuis moscou avec notre
correspondant très à gauche man
une longue conversation selon le kremlin
a eu lieu entre vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron selon le communiqué de
la présidence russe le sujet principal
de l'entretien était la question de leur
trop à la russie de garanties de
sécurité
il s'agit des propositions russes émises
fin 2021 sur l' architecture de la
sécurité européenne dans le contexte des
récentes négociations russo américaines
à genève et de la réunion du conseil
russie otan à bruxelles là des murs
poutine a noté que la partie russe
étudiera attentivement les réponses
écrites reçu le vent 6 janvier de la
part des états unis et de l'otan et
décidera ensuite des démarches à
entreprendre je vous propose d'écouter
lors de la discussion sur la situation
en ukraine vladimir poutine a souligné
l'importance du strict respect par kiev
des dispositions du paquet de mesures de
minsk et d'autres accords principalement
sur l'établissement d'un dialogue direct
avec donetsk est lougansk ainsi que sur
la régularisation au niveau juridique du
statut spécial du dombass compte tenu
des résultats de la réunion des
conseillers politiques des dirigeants
des quatre pays du format normandie qui
s'est tenue à paris le 26 janvier la
volonté de poursuivre le travail commun
de la russie et de la france au sein de
ce format a été confirmée la situation
en ukraine a été également discutés
après la réunion qui a eu lieu le 26
janvier à paris des conseillers
politiques des chefs d'état des pays
membres du format normandie aps le
président vladimir poutine a réitéré
l'importance du respect des accords de
mise écoutez l'attention a été attirée
sur le fait que les réponses des états
unis et de l'otan ne tenez pas compte
des préoccupations fondamentales de la
russie telles que le caractère
inadmissible de l'extension de l'otan le
renoncement à déployer des systèmes
d'armes de frappe près des frontières
russes ainsi que le retour du potentiel
militaire et de l'infrastructure de
l'alliance atlantique à leur position de
1997 année de signature de l'acte
fondateur sur les relations entre la
russie et l'otan plus tôt dans la
matinée c'est le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov qui s'est exprimé
sur le dossier ukrainien et sur les
spéculations quant à l'imminence d'une
attaque russe le ministre des affaires
étrangères a affirmé qu'il n'y aurait
pas de guerre si cela dépendait
uniquement de la russie mais a mis en
garde contre des forces extérieures qui
souhaiteraient une escalade dans la
région et la résolution de la crise
ukrainienne passe par des discussions au
format normandie discussions également
entre les européens et discussions avec
l'otan et les états unis washington qui
a racheté l'une des principales
revendications de moscou le nom
élargissement de l'alliance atlantique à
l'est à l'ouest de la russie
le regard du géopolitologue alexandre
del valle
c'est assez extraordinaire de voir des
américains décider avec qui les
européens doivent négocier
jusqu'où doit s'étendre les frontières
de l'otan et de l'union européenne et
avec ee est acquis les européens
devraient acheter du gaz monsieur macron
a à a essayé de deux procès d une
désescalade l'entretien s'est plutôt
bien passé et on ne peut que se
féliciter de cette de cet état de fait
de cette initiative française qui
rappelle celle de sarkozy en 2008 pour
la géorgie mais malheureusement il n'est
pas certain que ça soit extrêmement
écouter et par l'otan et par les états
unis et malheureusement aussi par les
partenaires de la france au sein de
l'union européenne
comme vous le savez le président en
exercice le pays qui a six mois de
gouvernance européenne qui préside
pendant six mois n'a pas une marge de
manoeuvre énorme il gère un peu l'agenda
mais les décisions ça reste les membres
de l'union européenne les états et bien
sûr avec une double lecture entre l'ailé
le conseil et le parlement et autres
entretiens d'ordre a1 diplomatique
toujours entre joe biden et volodymyr
zelensky ce le président américain a
échangé jeudi avec son homologue
ukrainien depuis la question agite les
médias quelle a été la teneur de ces
discussions selon les premiers éléments
dévoilés la conversation ne se seraient
pas bien déroulées une version corrigée
depuis par la maison blanche ou retrouve
à washington notre correspondant thomas
gonesse
thomas bonsoir expliquez-nous thomas cet
imbroglio feront tour de cet entretien
bien vous le savez les deux hommes ont
des échanges réguliers depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines et ce fut donc encore
le cas ce jeudi et comme à l'accoutumée
la maison blanche a publié un communiqué
de quelques lignes pour expliquer la
teneur des échanges entre les deux
hommes on y apprenait qu'il avait parlé
de leur collaboration et d'une réponse
ferme et coordonnées en cas d'agression
russe contre l'ukraine mais dans le même
temps des essais hier soir cnn
affirmaient qu'une source officielle
ukrainienne leur avait expliqué qu'en
réalité la discussion s'était mal passé
avec un point d'accroc le niveau de
risques exacts encourus par le cren face
à une potentielle invasion russe alors
toulouse toujours selon cette source
citée par cnn le président ukrainien ne
serait pas véritablement sur la même
ligne que celle de joe biden quant à
l'imminence d'une attaque russe le
président américain aurait ainsi déclaré
qu'une invasion russe était pratiquement
certaine demandant à volodimir zelensky
de se tenir prêts pour l'impact le
président ukrainien qui aurait quant à
lui demandé de calmer ces messages qui
dit-il créer de la panique alors face à
cet imbroglio provost provoquées par ces
récits contradictoires une conseillère
de la maison blanche a fini par réagir
corrigeant publiquement les informations
rapportées par sienne écoutez là
ce n'est pas vrai le président by dane a
dit qu'il y avait une réelle possibilité
que les russes envahissent l'ukraine en
février il avait déjà dit publiquement
et nous l'avons alerter sur ce sujet
depuis des mois dire autre chose serait
totalement faux
l'ambassade d'ukraine aux états unis lui
a emboîté le pas en expliquant qu'il y
avait de mauvaises informations qui
avaient été publiées alors cette
histoire pourrait s'arrêter là mais ce
vendredi le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky a tenu un point
presse il a adopté là encore un discours
relativement modérée appelant les
occidentaux et particulièrement les
médias occidentaux au calme je vous
propose d'écouter un extrait de son
discours
aujourd'hui nous n'assistons pas à une
escalade plus importante qu'auparavant
où il le nombre de militaires a augmenté
mais j'ai parlé de cela au début de
l'année 2000 21 quand ils ont parlé des
exercices militaires de la fédération de
russie
d'après la couverture médiatique des
événements on dirait que nous sommes
déjà en guerre que les troupes sont déjà
sur les routes qui lie à une
mobilisation avec des gens qui vont
quelque part ce n'est pas le cas nous
n'avons pas besoin de cette panique
alors même si le président ukrainien
réfute tout accrochage avec joe biden
lors de leurs échanges téléphoniques
d'hier force est de constater que les
propos qui ont été tenus ce vendredi
accrédite la thèse selon laquelle il y à
une divergence d'opinion de points de
vue entre kiev et washington sur
l'imminence d'une attaque russe contre
l'ukraine il a également donc parlé à
des médias occidentaux il faut bien
comprendre qu'ici aux états unis le
climat est plutôt à l'alarmisme de la
part des médias américains qui tiennent
une position très ferme très durs contre
la russie c'est d'ailleurs une position
qui est partagé par une grande majorité
des représentants politiques aux etats
unis et c'est dans ce contexte qu'une
conférence de presse vient d'avoir lieu
au pentagone avec le secrétaire
américain à la défense il a expliqué
qu'un conflit n'était pas inéluctable
mais dans le même temps accompagné du
chef d'état major des armées aux etats
unis ils ont détaillé préciser les
différentes mesures que pourraient
prendre les états unis en cas de conflit
en ukraine le chef d'état major
américain a ainsi expliqué qu'une
attaque russe à grande échelle aurait
des conséquences je cite épouvantable
merci beaucoup thomas bonnin directeur
de washington
le burkina faso suspendu de la
communauté des états ouest africains en
décisions prises par la cedeao fou lors
d'un sommet virtuel ce matin en réponse
aux coups d'état militaires d'il ya
quatre jours pour l'instant aucune autre
sanction n'a été décidé l'organisation
se réunira à nouveau le 3 février
prochain à accra elle demande par
ailleurs la libération du président
renversé
retour sur les évènements de lundi au
burkina avec un maillage brûler
un coup de force militaire mais une
opportunité pour réconcilier le peuple
burkinabé
lors de sa première allocution télévisée
le colonel damiba tient à rassurer sur
ses intentions et demande de l'aide à la
communauté internationale as un moment
particulièrement difficile pour notre
pays le burkina faso a plus que jamais
besoin de ses partenaires c'est pourquoi
j'appelle la communauté internationale
à accompagner notre pays afin qu'ils
puissent sortir le plus rapidement
possible de cette crise pour reprendre
sa marche vers le développement
arrivé au pouvoir ce lundi après avoir
évincé le président à la tête du pays
depuis 2015 le colonel damiba a promis
en retour constitutionnel dans les plus
brefs délais il a reçu ce jeudi les
différentes organisations syndicales
ainsi que l'ex chef de l'opposition
objectif selon les mots du nouvel homme
fort du pays restaurer une paix durable
avec les forces vives de la nation
je sois là surtout pour mettre dans sa
base
à voir les invités de nicolas appert et
la sécurité des populations
depuis six ans les attaque jihadiste de
plus en plus fréquentes menaces
quotidiennement la sécurité de la
population
il y a quelques jours au moins dix
civils ont été tués dans le nord du pays
ces dernières semaines les burkinabé
sont descendus dans les rues pour
demander la démission du désormais ex le
président roch marc christian kaboré
jugé incapable d'assurer la sécurité de
son peuple à l'afrique de l'ouest dans
la spirale des putschs militaires car
avant le burkina c'est la guinée qui a
vécu un coup d'état en septembre après
le mali en août le mali ont froid avec
la france qui l'accusent qui accuse pour
un militaire a dit légitimité dans un
entretien ce matin le chef de la
diplomatie française pointe cela
véritable fuite en avant de la junte ce
qui est inacceptable selon ses mots jean
yves le drian qui souhaitent adapter le
dispositif des forces européennes son
homologue malien lui a répondu il dit ne
rien exclure dans ses relations avec
paris
ce sont des propos empreints de mépris
ce sont des propos que je condamne qui
sont inacceptables et je crois que les
insultes ne sont pas une preuve de
grandeur nous sommes disposés à discuter
avec la france ou d'autres sur des
questions de substance il ne s'agit pas
de questions irresponsable ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est de défendre les
intérêts de notre pays toute présence
étrangère au niveau du mali doit
répondre aux règles malienne doit aussi
aller dans le sens des intérêts
supérieurs du mali surtout pour la
présence des forces étrangères et
décryptage à présent de la situation
avec un régis le sommier grand reporter
et france
bonsoir régis merci d'être avec nous les
relations ne cesse de se dégrader entre
la france plus largement les européens
et la jante malienne comment est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé là
alors c'est un long processus lent
processus qui qui a commencé en fait
bien largement avant le coup d'état
d'août 2020 qui a amené cette junte au
pouvoir avec à sa tête le colonel waseem
hugo et à l actuel président du mali
disons que il y a comment au mali il ya
eu des années pendant des années donc le
défunt président puisqu'il vient de
mourir comment ibrahim keita
à comment assurer la présidence
justement et n'est pas parvenu à comment
dire apporter une sécurité en dépit du
de l'après l'immense présence de barkan
à ses côtés la corruption s'est
généralisée dans le pays et beaucoup de
choses lui sont attribués aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que on pense que fin
beaucoup de maliens sont persuadés qu'
une partie de l'iqlim nettement de leur
pays qui est devenu il faut le rappeler
un est quasiment un état failli ne
contrôlant plus des pans entiers de son
territoire et bien sont dus à cette
président seydoux le coup d'état qui a
eu lieu en août 2009 un coup d'état qui
est jugé par certains maliens tout à
fait légitime mais les militaires ont
été applaudis à comment à ce moment là
et donc les forces là comment la khl à
la coalition les forces barkan comment
la france puis ses partenaires ont été
évidemment considérez-vous sont
considérés aujourd'hui de plus en plus
par les maliens comme des forces
étrangères qui occupent le pays c'est
une usure une certaine façon d'un oeil
qui rit qui est dû à ses huit années de
barkan et le fait que la junte au
pouvoir aussi s'autorise à aller voir
d'autres partenaires et en l'occurrence
le vrai point de tension c'est les
pourparlers qui ont eu lieu pendant ces
derniers mois avec donc la milice privée
wagner russe donc et donc de ceux de ce
point de vue là les français considèrent
comme insupportables que finalement une
aura notre notre entité militaires
puissent prendre leur place au mali
alors il ya eu aussi une sorte
d'intransigeance qui s'est établi que la
part des autorités maliennes qui
aujourd'hui refusent tout ne demande est
mis au courant de tout
mouvement de troupes et on l'a vu avec
dans le cadre de la force takouba vous
c'est qu'à force takouba c'était voilà
une manière de remplacer par cannes est
actuellement c'est la force qui remplace
barque anomalie cette force elle est
composée de forces spéciales européennes
des des suédois des tchèques des
français évidemment qui vont qui sont
quand même qu'ils restent l'ossature de
cette force et elle devait aussi se
composait de forces spéciales danoise
les autorités maliennes avaient donné
avait dit qu'elle étudier cette
possibilité
les danois sont arrivés et le
gouvernement malien a demandé au
danemark de retirer ses troupes et le
danemark a dû obtempérer donc là c'est
véritablement un camouflet pour la force
takouba parce que c'est sans forces
spéciales comme en plus qui sont retirés
et on peut se demander puisque les
suédois ont annoncé début janvier que
ils retireraient leurs troupes également
à un moment donné n'ont pas donné de
date précise mais quel va être l'avenir
de cette présence parce que cette
présence conditionnent tout la présence
française militaire au mali et on sait
déjà que barkan a retiré une partie de
ses troupes en tout cas n'y a plus de
troupes françaises dans le nord du mali
et ses troupes de takouba elles sont
très importantes aussi parce que elles
sont pour la formation le voit à l'écran
là actuellement ses ailes sont des
troupes qui assure la formation de
l'armée malienne à travers des petites
unités très bien entraîné donc les
partenaires de l'effort spéciale donc
forme l'armée malienne justement pour
aller comment essayer justement de
reprendre le pays une grosse difficulté
puisque encore une fois comme je le
disais au début le mali reste un pays
extrêmement morcelé extrêmement éclaté
dans lequel finalement des des zones
entières
l'extension des zones entières
l'activité s'est totalement réduite et
sur ces zones est bien le gouvernement
central n'exerce plus d'autorité jean
yves le drian l'a déclaré ce matin la
france et ses partenaires européens ne
peuvent pas rester comme cela c'est ce
qu'il a dit à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre
c'est très commencer un tournant
actuellement en étant on le voit aussi
avec le coup d'état ou burkina faso il
ya eu coup d'état en guinée aussi
même au niveau de ce qu'on appelle la
cedeao qui est donc à communauté des
pays d'afrique de l'ouest sur laquelle
la france a encore une influence mais on
se rend compte que un certain nombre de
ces de ces pays le mali le burkina la
guinée par exemple non plus n'ont aucune
n'hésite pas ouvertement à critiquer
c'est un set cette instance et à ne pas
lui obéir notamment dans les sanctions
l'ue et la guinée a dit qu'elle
n'appliquerait pas les sanctions qui ont
été décidées contre le mali
récemment c'est à dire la fermeture des
échanges des autres pays avec le mali
donc il y a de plus en plus c'est
gouvernement de transition alors cédé
gouvernement de transition qui sont
censés rendre le pouvoir à un pouvoir
civil on établit un calendrier puis on
s'aperçoit en tout cas pour le moment au
mali que ce calendrier n'a pas été tenu
et que ce sont toujours les militaires
au pouvoir gouvernement de transition
l'a également au tchad a également cédé
militaires qui sont au pouvoir en guinée
il ya une multiplication de ces
gouvernement de transition dirigé par
des militaires alors est ce que ça
signifie que c'est la fin de ce qu'on a
appelé globalement la françafrique c'est
à dire que la règle influence française
aujourd'hui se réduit on voit de plus en
plus de voix qui contestent donc parmi
ses dirigeants la présence et l'activité
de la france ces déploiements et le fait
que des déploiements militaires
européens soit opérée sur le sol manière
en particulier et que ben voilà tout ça
mais en question l'avenir des relations
de la france c'était une période quand
même très compliqué une période comme on
peut être un tournant justement dans les
relations entre la france et l'afrique
de l'ouest en france ancienne puissance
coloniale qui conserve de l' influence
mais qui on le voit on a de moins en
moins merci beaucoup régis le sommier
pour votre décryptage de résister seul
mais grand reporter à air tahiti ce
plus de 19 milliards de dollars dès 2022
l'argentine faisait face à de lourdes
échéances de remboursement sur trois ans
elles annoncent aujourd'hui un accord
avec le fmi sur sa dette une réduction
progressive de son déficit public les
explications depuis les loisonnais
c'est un accord synonyme de soulagement
pour la deuxième puissance économique
d'amérique latine alors que l'argentine
aurait dû rembourser plus de 19
milliards de dollars en 2022 à peu près
autant en 2023 et environ 4 milliards en
2024 le pays vient de gagner du temps et
de s'autoriser un avenir économique plus
optimistes
gouverner est un exercice de
responsabilité nous avions un problème
et maintenant nous avons une solution
nous avions une corde autour du cou une
épée de damoclès et maintenant nous
avons un chemin que nous pouvons suivre
sans accord nous n'avions pas d'horizon
pour l'avenir avec cet accord nous
pouvons régler le présent et construire
un avenir
par rapport aux accords précédents
signés par l'argentine et il est bon de
le rappeler cet accord ne prévoit pas de
restriction qui retarderait notre
développement
contractée il ya près de quatre ans
auprès de l'institution internationale
le prêt d'un montant initial de 57
milliards de dollars constitué à lui
seul 43% des prêts du fmi soit la plus
importante dette accorder un état par
l'institution depuis fin 2010 9 le
nouveau gouvernement dialogue avec le
fonds monétaire international pour
renégocier cette dette jugée
insoutenable objectif atteint contre un
certain nombre d'engagements de la part
de buenos aires est ce pas là l'année
prochaine à un déficit fiscal prime à un
déficit budgétaire primaire de 2 5% du
produit intérieur brut est prévue pour
2022 1 9% pour 2023 et 0 29% pour 2024
napoli nous serons en mesure d'avoir une
politique fiscale qui n'entrave pas la
continuité la reprise l'état pourra
jouer un rôle modérément expansionniste
avec une croissance modérée des dépenses
en termes réels
si l'argentine a gagné du temps le pays
est l'institution monétaire doivent
encore travailler plusieurs semaines sur
les protocoles d'accord le nouveau
calendrier des échéances devrait être
annoncée au terme de cette période
en france christiane taubira rassure
qu'elle reconnaîtra que le verdict de la
primaire à populaire le vote ça des
morts a démarré jeudi les résultats est
attendue dimanche soir résultats accueil
à nick shadow anne hidalgo et jean luc
mélenchon ne reconnaîtront pas à eux ils
continuent de mener leurs campagnes
ainsi du candidat de la france insoumise
qui a exposé sa vision de la france hier
c'était sur le plateau de ces huit sites
olypiques à eau
[Musique]
face à une dizaine d'intervenants de
tous bords dont eric zemmour
le candidat de l'union populaire à
l'élection présidentielle a déroulé son
programme pour commencer jean luc
mélenchon a exposé sa vision de
l'immigration
le député la france insoumise veut par
exemple donner la nationalité française
aux étrangers qui entrent légalement en
france
sur l'immigration la première des choses
c'est une politique qui s'occupe
réellement de faire en sorte que les
gens n'aient pas besoin de partir mais
une fois qu'ils sont là je refuse de les
maltraiter il faut traiter les gens
humainement le député a mis l'accent sur
le regroupement familial pour mieux
intégrer les immigrés je suis partisan
du regroupement familial car je crois
qu'un homme ou une femme qui a immigré
se comportera d'une manière plus facile
avec la société
s'il assume la responsabilité de sa
famille autre thème phare de jean luc
mélenchon le pouvoir d'achat le candidat
souhaite aider les plus pauvres
notamment à se nourrir la france vit
déjà dans la misère 9 millions de
français sont pauvres 8 millions de
personnes vont à l'aide alimentaire 12
millions de personnes ont froid c'est à
cette urgence qu'il faut répondre jean
luc mélenchon n'oublie pas les jeunes
électorat phare pour lui il souhaite
axer les héritages et reverser cet
argent aux étudiants lorsqu un héritage
sera supérieure à 12 millions d'euros je
prendrai tout ce qu'il y aura au dessus
cela permettra de financer une
allocation d'autonomie pour tous les
jeunes gens de la seconde
professionnelle au bts et à l'université
enfin face à sofia show via fille de
cédric chou via mort en janvier 2020
suite à une interpellation musclée de la
police le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle est revenue sur les
violences policières des violences qu'il
dénonce je crois en la police
républicaine ceux qui se sont couverts
d'opprobre et ont ridiculisé
l'institution par des comportements
racistes seront expulsés de la police
nationale si je suis élu je réformerai
tout au sujet de la police ceux qui se
sont rendus coupables d'actes criminels
seront punis et certains ne seront plus
membre de la police nationale car ils en
sont indignes une intervention d'un peu
moins de quatre heures très commentée
sur les réseaux sociaux à moins de trois
mois de l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 ici en 2017 jean luc mélenchon
est parvenu à créer un élan derrière sa
candidature selon arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire les cinq années qui
viennent de s'écouler ont peut-être joué
en sa défaveur écouter
l'espoir de jean luc mélenchon c'est se
retrouver dans la situation car lui même
que l'acceptation de 2017 ou à peu près
à la même époque au gouvernement a
convié il était sûr de son talent
étaient entre 9 et 10 et il a fini à dix
neuf voire frôlant pratiquement la
qualification se gonfle ou est-ce que
aujourd'hui il est en mesure de réaliser
à nouveau ce parcours était par contre
quand même extrêmement important sur le
plan de l'efficacité électorale c'est
difficile de lire parce que lui aussi
appelé les conditions d'un désunion à
gauche le
lilas un quinquennat est entre
guillemets qui est impec et nac et ces
deux coups d'éclat de rupture de
conflictuelle it et toutes ces deux
traits de caractère parfois peuvent en
effet irrité un certain nombre de ses
partenaires la primaire populaire n'est
pas en soi il un qui a été montée contre
jean luc mélenchon c'est en tout cas en
effet un dispositif qui me semble qu'ils
le regard de ce qu'on voit de la scène
politique à gauche semble en tout cas à
rajouter de la division à la division
est loin de clarifier les choses tantôt
les obscurcir s à la fin de cette
édition se retrouve un à 21h pour un
nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et vit la
population africaine c'est un milliard
d'habitants c'est ça à la valeur de nos
crypto monnaie notre objectif c'est
d'avoir de plus en plus de partenaires
qui acceptent notre crypto comme moyen
de paiement qu'en ce crash qui nous dit
que l'argent liquide perd de la valeur
beaucoup de pays en afrique ont interdit
la crypto est ce que vous répondez à
cela une planète on ne peut pas dire on
va interdire la crypto autant qu'il ya
internet il y aura des crues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]